our goal is to make the best personal
computers in the world and make products
we are proud to sell and would recommend
to our family and friends but i have to
tell you there's some stuff in our
industry that we wouldn't be proud to
ship there are thresholds that we can't
cross because of who we are and we can't
do it
we just can't ship junk bruh oh how i
wish that steve was still running apple
now maybe it wouldn't be a three
trillion dollar company but bs like this
probably wouldn't have happened here we
are though and with the current
landscape we have to be honest about
this machine which shouldn't exist at
least with the configuration and pricing
that it's at now this won't just be a
hater video there'll be a lot of that
but i'll also mention who this machine
will be good for and its strings now let
me take a step back and say yes we have
been pretty negative about this macbook
pro fueled by apple apologists that
always seemed to take their side along
with our viewers that pushed us to do
more testing to get to the bottom of
these issues and those who disputed our
findings saying that they don't matter
in the real world with that many people
who walk into a retailer and pick up one
of these base models which is the one
that is stocked everywhere as long as
they're using it the same way the apple
markets the macbook air they will be
fine and they won't notice any issues
especially if they're coming from an
intel mac but if that person looked at
apple's marketing page talking about
portable editing bays capable of
multi-stream ak advanced thermal systems
for sustained pro levels for performance
for cpu and gpu intensive tasks for
hours on end and super fast ssds opening
everything up in a flash and then pro
level tasks like video editing
transcoding photo stitching and image
processing way faster than an m1 well
you might not be as thrilled if you want
to do these tasks especially if you have
a few web browsing tabs open and two
applications and the m2 is taking
seconds longer just to switch tabs or
images in photoshop with both systems
being used the exact same way i have
done all of those tasks with my m1s and
i know more than five creatives that
make well into the six figures using
2020 m1s because they do the job more
than well enough and they push their
systems way harder than we did in our
tests because of that in apple's
marketing i don't buy the premise that
the 13-inch pro isn't for pros it is for
pros those that might not be able to
afford the clearly better 14-inch model
and those that didn't have to be four
because even the base m1 macbook air did
a killer job for productivity and
multitasking as we've shown in our
videos and the premise that people who
care about performance won't buy the
base model well within our own audience
that clearly cares about performance
because they watch our video based on
our affiliate sales close to three times
as many people bought the base models
compared to higher spec ones with that
unlike the m1 macbook pro apple is not
selling the 16 gigabyte m2 models in
stores now and this speaks to our
opinion that the whole reason for this
machine is to push more people into
buying a 14 inch macbook pro now the m2
chip isn't bad it is far from it it is a
good improvement over the m1 if it is
paired with a dual nand storage setup
and 16 gigabytes of ram it ends up
reaching the marketed numbers the apple
shows off and being super fast for all
sorts of stuff like photo processing
taking just one minute and seven seconds
to process 50 raw images in adobe
lightroom classic that is crazy fast and
it smokes the competition and then if
you're multitasking it barely slows down
taking just seven seconds longer
exporting video and davinci resolve 18
is blazing fast as well for this
specific configuration as are so many
other things the only issue is that the
14 inch is even faster at all this with
much better features and it's only 100
more since it's constantly on sale so
most people that are still interested in
the 13 inch are on a budget and they're
getting the pro for the active cooling
compared to the air meaning they do want
to do productivity tests but the base
model is much slower than the optimal
one almost twice as low for image
processing if you have nothing else open
and we have never seen a difference this
big between two configurations with the
same exact chip and that is of course
because of the slow base ssd that is
even slower than a 600
64 gigabyte ipad air and the reason why
it makes such an impact on performance
is because of the way apple silicon is
designed and their unified memory that
makes the chips so dang fast and
responsive as long as it's being fed
fast enough but it can also slow down
way more than an intel mac if you have
slow storage that's used for swap heck
have you seen your intel mac take 12
seconds to switch between a photo like
this base model took while the optimal
one was instant as soon as we clicked
the right arrow now this won't always
happen we did have two productivity apps
open and 10 web browsing tabs so if you
only use one app at a time and you close
your web browser whenever you do you
will be fine but this isn't something we
had to do with our m1s now if that is
pushing it too hard even with five web
browsing tabs and one app the base model
m1 air you could buy for 850 dollars for
now at least was almost twice as fast
under the same workload so those that
say the apple skimming on ssds doesn't
really make a difference in the real
world please do some actual testing
before throwing shade at us on social
media video editing is almost identical
in final cut if you only have final cut
open but with web browsing and photoshop
open like i often do have the base m2
pro is more than twice as slow i don't
care what your justifications are under
no circumstance should a fanless 2020
base model m1 air with a bin 7 core
graphics that's often sold for 850 bucks
be able to be twice as fast as a brand
new m2 pro machine that is heavily
marketed for these tasks and yes they
were set up identically down to how much
storage is actually used on that 256 gig
ssd some have called our deep testing
showing off these issues unethical
because people won't buy these machines
if they watch our videos if they read
the titles well we think that it is
unethical for apple to make a product
like this and market it so heavily while
knowing that most people will buy the
base model and they are with the base
model being a number 17 on amazon top
100 laptop list while the 512gb version
was number 73 and of course the 16 gig
isn't even a stock model at all now
after all of this i think there is
really only one reason why apple chose
to do this and no it's not because of
the chip shortage or western digital's
chip losses apple doesn't use their
storage ships in their macbooks and the
ssd prices have dropped a ton over the
last year it is pure profit the m1
laptops were way too good we told a lot
of you guys that you should just be fine
even with a base model and we showed you
guys the proof in our multitasking ram
stress test
a lot of my creative professional
friends bought them to use temporarily
as they waited for their higher end
apple silk and macbooks to come out but
once they did they didn't upgrade
because the m1s handled all of their
tough workflows perfectly fine so how do
you get people to spend more money
you make the base product worse so
people have to spend more and then you
don't stock the 16 gig model so many
people will just jump to their real pro
laptops the 14 and 16 engines and then
if they do end up custom ordering and
waiting you will make massive profit
margins on this machine where most of
the parts are from 2016 already now some
people say that they had to go with a
slower single storage chip because 128
gigabyte modules are harder to get now
and they're more expensive than 256 is
but that is the point a pro machine
shouldn't come with 256 gigabytes in
2022 anyway dell starts the xps 13 plus
with 512 gigs now and that is a much
faster ssd than even the higher end
options of the macbook pro a lot of
these slowdowns wouldn't have happened
if it shipped with 512 as the base and
it would cost apple no more than two
dollars and seven cents to make it a
gig machine
yes that is how little one of those
chips costs likely even less since apple
orders in huge volumes so it's not
really the availability or the price of
the storage like apple apologists stated
but the fact that them spending two
dollars would lose them a 200 upgrade
that way more people are now doing
because of our testing so it is in fact
working in their favor so let's meet in
the middle apple how about raise this
profit margin machine to 1400 instead of
13 so all of the pro marketing machines
have 512 as a base you still get the
recycled design from 2016 with the 720p
webcam worst speakers than even the m1
air no fast charging no mag safe so you
have to use one of the two ports to
charge well then apple would probably be
in a similar situation where pros that
are on the budget would spend less and
not be guided up that perfect staircase
where moving up in spec and model it
just kind of makes sense because you
spend a little bit more and you do get
an increase in performance the m1
machines broke that because they were
too dang good but now the lineup works
perfectly the m2 air is for regular
people that don't have too high
expectations because of the fanless
design the m2 pro is for pros as it is
marketed but the base model is worse
than the m1 if you multitask so you need
the 512 but if you really want them to
chip to work as advertised you need the
16 gig model which isn't sold in stores
so if you need a quick you'll just spend
more money and go for a 14 inch for 2
000 bucks and if you do end up spending
1700 on a 16 gig 512 model well then
apple gets to make massive amounts of
profit and at that point they don't
really care that you didn't buy a 14
inch now a few more positives on this
machine the battery life is excellent it
just lasts forever like we've seen in
the last two weeks of use even if you're
pushing it with heavy cpu and gpu
workloads
it just keeps running and running and
then for light uses it is absolutely
insane now of course you don't get the
fast charging so when it does come time
to charge it will take you about twice
as long as the m2 macbook air now along
with that of course it has that fan and
that's what apple is marketing so for
those extended workloads it will perform
better and maintain the performance for
most of the tasks that you do
compared to them to macbook air which
will slow down for those extended uses
so that is a benefit now of course we
talked about the heating issues it
definitely gets hot a part of that is
because apple waits a long time to ramp
up the fans which you can fix yourself
but that is also a plus compared to
windows laptops where oftentimes even
downloading or you know extracting a
file web browsing you'll get fan noise
this thing acts like like a fanless
macbook most of the time which is a
benefit but overall this is probably the
worst macbook that apple has ever
released when you factor in the target
audience and the marketing as well as
the previous model that was released and
the other models that are currently
available and we believe that almost
nobody should buy it and unfortunately
that's probably what apple wants either
to spend more money get high specs a lot
of profit margins or for you to step up
and spend more money now sure many
people that will go in and that will buy
base model they will be happy with it
will be better than their old macbook
that is years old or a windows laptop
but that still doesn't make it ethical
or right uh making these kind of cuts
and making the product a lot worse than
it should be especially compared to
older cheaper machines that they
released that people absolutely loved
but you guys let us know your thoughts
down in the comment section below if
you're considering how it compares to a
14 inch or maybe even an m1 macbook air
that you can buy for 850 bucks check out
those videos right there click above to
subscribe this been max for max tech and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]